and she started using the printing out
transcripts of Khan Academy - and
get-and giving him these sheets of the
stacks of paper when she visited him in
prison and through just the transcripts
Jason was able to start realizing that
he you know in school he what you know
he felt weak in math but now he's like I
can learn this stuff and his sentence
was was taken down from 30 years to
still 15 years so now in his mid-30s
he's released from prison he's feeling
more confident about his knowledge he
goes to Community College and then he's
able to use Khan Academy properly with
the videos and the exercises what a lot
of y'all are familiar with and then he
decides he wants to transfer to a
four-year college he uses the SAT prep
that we do in partnership with the
College Board and he starts doing quite
well and I mean this is what's really
mind-blowing at age 35 he was able to
stick to transfer to Stanford University
as a computer science student and that
was the Jason who and you know by the
end of the story we were all tearing up
this was as powerful and then I asked
him I was like hey whatever one leaves
can I take my phone out and just video
you because I think your story obviously
it's it's something that we love to
share in forums like this when we're
we're we're pleading for people to
realize that hey Kahn Academy needs your
help but it's also an inspiring story
because you know I think we all have
days where we're like Oh things could be
a little bit easier or I had that
setback or that setback when you when
you hear a story like Jason's you
realize that most of our setbacks are
fairly small in comparison to what he's
what he has gone through and then and
you see how far far he's gone and he
still has setbacks what's amazing how
positive he is I mean you know when you
have a prison record it's still hard to
get internships still hard to get jobs
even if even if you have Stanford on
your resume so you know I think it's
it's always good I mean we know where
Thanksgiving was last week but I'm still
in kind of the Thanksgiving mode I think
it's we all need to really appreciate
how good most of us have it don't look
at that and Jason appreciates how good
he has it even though he's had a tough
beginning but we have more donations
Rita thank you Rita
really appreciate it
just joining us live - okay all right so
you - so so just explain what's going on
here yeah you wanna yeah for sure so
today is giving Tuesday and Khan Academy
we are a non-profit so we are asking for
your support today and we have a goal of
raising five thousand dollars during
this live stream and during this live
stream we'll call out people who do
donate and also take your questions so
if you have any questions please put it
in the comments of this livestream and
we'll try to get to as many as we as we
can and we might also call out people
who aren't donating we would do it if we
knew how but we don't know a few people
got scared well well thanks Javon for
for donating means a lot and people can
donate on Facebook there's a place to do
it on YouTube there's a place so that's
a new feature they added yes yes there's
a place to donate button somewhere
around someplace
top right yeah and and if we raise
$5,000 before we show it I don't know
yeah it should be motivation enough Khan
Academy is a not-for-profit has a
mission of free world-class education
for anyone anywhere your donation will
literally help us serve tens of millions
of people and as we explained to the
Facebook users we're live streaming on
YouTube and Facebook yep simultaneously
very high-tech yeah as we explained a
not-for-profit like Khan Academy no one
owns it
I don't know Khan Academy Lizzy doesn't
own Khan Academy it's a public good we
were employees of Khan Academy but your
donations is what allows us to continue
to provide things for free you see a lot
of things on the internet that seem free
but they're making money off of you in
some way shape or form they're feeding
you ads which you don't realize it but
that's
programming your brain and sometimes
shady ways they are maybe they have some
kind of freemium they're going to try to
sell you something at some point or
they're gonna do something suspicious
with you not always suspicious but
they're gonna do something with your
data but as a not-for-profit and not
only is it not for profit
we're supported by philanthropy and all
right you know our goal is keep Khan
Academy free make sure that our bottom
line is not profit our bottom line is
our mission free world-class education
for anyone anywhere so hopefully that is
motivation enough to donate to Khan
Academy but just to put some of you on
the edge over the edge not on the edge
over over the line on top of that if
we're able to raise $5,000 over the next
half hour I will explain this notorious
orders of operations problem which it's
fascinating how popular this is but I
think you know it's most of you all know
this but and and also Lizzy and I are
answering questions and and we're also
doing shout outs to people like a dear
who just gave a donation so so thank you
Victoria Frey I think mentioned Victoria
yet well thank you Victoria so it does
look like we have some questions that
are already coming in so um what is your
advice for when you can't get your SAT
score up all right
SAT score so I think there's a couple
things so before even thinking about how
to get the SAT score up or you know it's
just a reminder we did this we made a
video about like distressing the SCT
first appreciate that you are not your
SAT score I think especially when you
are in the later stages of high school
and you're in this period where you're
applying to college I know this is
happening to a lot of students right now
or maybe there's a lot of juniors who
are starting to think about the process
for next year it can seem like your
whole identity is going to be defined by
your grades your extracurriculars your
SAT score where you go to college etc
etc everyone's comparing and that's not
the healthiest thing in the world and
we've all been there but I think you
know what you're going to realize is
over the broader broader sweep of your
life that these are all just very minor
data points and you know I have we have
people who've
you know billionaires some of whom
who've you know donated to the Khan
Academy and their SAT scores were not so
impressive or their but they are very
impressive people they are very
entrepreneurial they were able to do
great things and they might have just
not been you know for whatever reason
you know great test takers or whatever
you whatever you want to call it so
that's my first foundational is like you
are not your SAT score you are not your
grades you are not defined by where you
go where you go to college and likewise
I know people with very good data points
who you know for various reasons have
had to you know struggle in various ways
so once again that's that's the
disclaimer yes and I I it's easy to
pretend that like you know like I'm
beyond all of this incomplete you know I
have to remind it to myself sometimes
yeah sometimes you you know you visit a
house with a friend with a massive house
and you're like oh this is nice no I'm
not defined by the square footage but
the the the my advice for you at 4-4 se
T early any test is you know one there's
direct advice we have the official SAT
practice that we've partnered with the
college board and we have many efficacy
studies that have showed that pretty
much every hour that you're able to
engage on the platform you are going to
grow and there are better ways to use
things like our official SAT practice I
would recommend taking as many practice
tests as you can when you take the
practice test try to simulate real
testing conditions as well as possible
after you've taken the test and you've
graded your tests look at what you got
wrong and go back to those questions and
and make sure that you understand how
they work you know I feel a lot of
people when they see a test especially
like a test like the SAT this like oh
this is hard there's just going to be
questions I don't know but it's worth
appreciating that the SAT especially the
SAT over the last several years
it really doesn't cover anything that
isn't taught outside of algebra 2 or
outside of the 10th grade so if you feel
pretty comfortable in that you shouldn't
look at anything and say oh this is some
type of mysterious quantum physics
calculus it's nothing like that's on the
SAT it's all stuff that you should
by the time you're in 10th grade so you
should feel confident that you can do
any problem reflect on what you weren't
able to do always work on the stuff that
you find maybe most challenging
sometimes it's a temptation for us to
work on the stuff that's easy yeah easy
for us and what I'm describing you this
would be true if you were you know
preparing for some type of a sport as
well practice what you're not good at
try to simulate real conditions when
possible do kind of that weak point
training and I would say rather than
binge prepare you know just do eight
hours all at once do if if you have
enough time let's say you're a month
away from the SAT try to put in 20
minutes a day if some days you're able
to put in more that's great but if
you're able to do that regular practice
and then maybe once a week do a full
form practice exam I think you're going
to be in in pretty pretty good shape and
I've already said this advice I was on
we were on Instagram there's a pre live
stream and I would say you know I've
actually been meditating a ton this this
especially the last year and a half it's
helped me just with all of the different
things in my life that's been like you
know with family and work and raising
money you can kind sometimes just get
really stressed and just you know at
first when you start meditating and you
you spend you know you start maybe five
ten minutes at a time now I'd do 30
minutes every morning you're like what
am i doing and your brain starts it goes
so are you wasting your time you have so
much to do but slowly your brain starts
to still and when you're in that kind of
a mode everything becomes easier and
ideally when you take the SAT you're in
that type of a mode you've gotten your
sleep you've got your your food and your
you're just ready to kind of just you
know and and and you do and you do what
you can and the chips fall where they do
you know one of the things that uh you
know as I was I
I've been interested in a lot of Eastern
philosophy ever since we did some of the
world history content on Khan Academy
and in Vedic philosophy and in kind of
the Hindu philosophy there's these
notions of kind of aspects of the
universe including in work and there's
there's soft wick work which is work
that is true work that you do because
you think it is right and but you're not
fixated on the outcome they could you
know
Rajasa quark is work where you are
somewhat fixated on the outcome I'm
gonna do this because we're gonna raise
five thousand dollars and if we don't
I'm gonna be really disappointed which I
will be or if I don't do this I'm gonna
get in trouble therefore I do it and
then you have Temasek work which is I'm
doing it because someone's forcing in me
I don't really want to do it I'm
dragging my feet um I'm not really into
it I think most of us are kind of in
this rajasic mode most of our lives
we're like I need a good SAT score and
if I don't get that I'm going to be
miserable and I'm going to suffer and as
Buddha says suffering is all caused by
attachment to especially attachment to
outcome and so I remind myself every day
and it's definitely stresses me and I
anyone you're preparing for a test or
anything in life try to take that
Southwick attitude you definitely put
work into it put energy in it do what
you think is right but don't be obsessed
with the outcome the outcome is what it
is if you do what you think is right the
chips fall where they do and then not
only will you find yourself less
stressed but you'll probably have better
outcomes as well when you're not
obsessed with them yeah that's a long
answer I've got a little bit more
preachy tonight yeah but super helpful
and great things to think even like what
I just said applies well beyond the SAT
and I still work on it let's see other
people
Monica Khan I may be related thank you
for your donation rocky Kirk thank you
CR chandramouli thank you and tweed um
thank you so much for your donations
let's see there's a funny comment so
when I hear Stiles voice I want to do
that that's great go do math yes another
question from YouTube how did you get
the idea to start Khan Academy oh that's
a lots all the story I'll give a short
version of it um oh I see you know from
a very early age I was actually very
fascinated by like education even in
undergrad you know when I was a CS major
math major I I was always fascinated by
how computers could be used to maybe
help teach people and I had some
projects there but I injury you know I
ended up working in tech I ended up
working eventually at a hedge fund which
is really just a fancy word for an
investment firm that
has more flexibility and and while I was
doing that I write after my wedding my
12 year old cousin Nadia just came out
of conversation that she was having
trouble and math so I offered to tutor
her remotely I was in Boston she was in
New Orleans so I started working with
her it was actually unit conversion she
was having trouble with she got through
that now she got caught up with her
class a little head of her class and at
that point it became what I call a tiger
cousin and I called up her school and I
think Nadia should retake that placement
test for this who are you I'm her cousin
and and they let her and then she was
actually put into an advanced math class
so I was a little bit hooked this was 15
years ago and then I started tutoring
her younger brothers and word spreads
around my family that free tutoring is
going on so I was tutoring like 10 15
cousins and then I fed hey these are
great guinea pigs for me to test some of
my ideas out on like software and so I
wrote some software for them from that
practice problems because all of them
their main issues they had gaps a lot of
them they were trying their best and
they were all a or B students but the
reason why they're having trouble in
algebra wasn't that algebra was
difficult it wasn't that they weren't
bright it's that you know they might
have been a little bit shaking on
negative numbers or a little bit shaky
on dividing decimals from fifth grade
and so I was their tutor to fill in
those gaps but also I wanted to give
them practice so that they could get
that feedback and that was the first
Khan Academy I had to put it on a
website someplace and the kind of
Caterpie domain name was that stuff like
math planet and and but it was kind of
it was kind of almost just a funny thing
so it's just like me and my cousins and
I kind of dreamt that maybe one day
other people could use this stuff and it
was actually a friend and had nothing to
do the videos initially and a friend
said how are you scaling your lessons
and I said I'm I'm not it's hard to do
with at that point I had 15 cousins that
I was able to do it Nadia and he says
why don't you make some videos and
upload them on to YouTube for your
family and immediately that was a
horrible idea I said you know YouTube's
for cats playing piano not serious math
many people have heard me say that but
it's actually that was the actual
interchange I it was either that or dogs
on skateboards but you get the idea and
and and and but I I got over the idea
that it wasn't my idea which is an
important thing in life and I gave it a
shot and you know those those are those
YouTube videos tried to get watched by
people who aren't my family and one
thing led to another and by 2010 2009 I
had trouble focusing on my day job
because there was about a hundred
thousand people were using this thing
called Khan Academy and so the 2008 I
had set it up as a not-for-profit and
then actually at the time I was hoping
if hey if I could do really well in the
investment world maybe one day in 10
years 20 years I would have enough money
to be able to retire and do this but
then events happen faster than I
expected and I didn't have anywhere near
enough money to do I was saving up money
for a down payment on our house and our
first child had been born but you know
kind of the zeitgeist of the world you
know something was was pulling was kind
of making me do this
but yeah and and quit my job it took a
while to get some of that first funding
and then we're still raising money
that's why we're here trying to raise
$5,000 I will do this order of
operations problem for you and you can
explain this to to family members and
impress co-workers and even social
gatherings
yeah like good holiday yeah I think if
you you know if you walk up to someone
that you might find appealing at a party
or something yeah I mean I think what's
cooler than that right and say you know
you might think order of operations is
boring let me tell you but anyway that's
that's how Khan Academy that's how and
then you know that was back in 2009 2010
and you know we've just been on a ride
together since and and it be clear Khan
Academy is much more than me now you see
some great people in this room and then
there's 200 people outside of this room
who help forward Khan Academy's mission
your donation helps us have a team that
can do this and there's actually
thousands of volunteers on top of that
engineers and content creators marketers
fundraisers yeah educators teachers we
have a thousand so all of what what your
donation you know just so people know we
have to spend many millions of dollars
just to keep this
servers going yeah on Khan Academy
operation so but in the in the course of
the next few minutes if we can raise
$5,000 so we have some more questions
that came in donations Todd Lee thank
you very much on and and Heather Diego
thank you so much don't eat it on
YouTube
you found the blue button cool um so
what is your favorite subject
my favorite subject you know I would
it's changed over time and it's it's
really um it's kind of whatever I'm into
at the moment you know I I would say
when I was growing up my favorite
subjects were you know probably people
wouldn't be surprised to hear math and
science but also I was really into art
growing up so those were my favorite
subjects I was I actually thought I was
going to be a cartoonist when I was so
obviously with the videos I found an
outlet to sketch room for people but now
you know through Khan Academy we've
worked on many subjects and I think the
key is realizing that almost every
subject is actually really really really
interesting you know someone on someone
on I think it was on Instagram had just
asked like how do I get the motivation
to study and for me it's because I have
to study for Khan Academy in fact me you
know I'm one of the few people over the
age of 40 that's the study for the same
things that many of you all have to
study to make sure that I but I never
want I don't want to study to just like
be able to go through the motions or
just to be able to get an answer right I
want to study to be able to appreciate
the mystery of the universe and when you
got to realize there's a lot of this
stuff that you might see in a textbook
or that you might see on Khan Academy or
in other places you know you might view
it as like oh I got to figure out how
this equation work so I got to figure
out what entropy means or this or that
but you have to you should be excited
because if for example you know there's
some notions of entropy these are things
that people pondered for hundreds or
thousands of years and some people
dedicated their entire careers to some
aspect
and you're able to open up a textbook or
click on a video in a sense you get the
answer and and and as always it spoils
it but then you're like you didn't
struggle with it that that long but you
should get excited in that way think
about how someone you know Isaac Newton
would have given anything to get a hand
get his hands on all of your textbooks
like you know anyone even a hundred
years ago would would give their arm to
get their hands on you know your
textbooks Khan Academy etc etc because
there's just so much knowledge in it so
when you have that mindset any subject
becomes really really really interesting
and for me I love to look at subjects
and start to realize connections that I
had never seen before so like I've
actually recently really gotten into
etymology because when you look at the
where words come from it starts to
actually even explain a lot you know one
of my favorite ones it's you know and if
if this doesn't impress you people that
impress people at social gatherings what
I'm about to tell you will so you know I
was talking about Eastern philosophy in
the Vedas the Vedas are 3500 or older
year old texts that are kind of the the
basis of Hinduism and Hindu philosophy
and in the Vanda the the most mentioned
God is Indra who's kind of the the sky
God and he has kind of aspects of like
four and Nordic mythology and in their
fathers mentioned in the Vedas ten times
as sky father and sky father is do
spotter in in in Sanskrit Jos father
Jupiter Zeus Potter so Jupiter
Zeus Potter and do spotter are all
essentially and this was one of the
first pieces of evidence when the
British came to India and they got some
of the the Hindu priests to say hey
teach a Sanskrit that was the first time
that they realized these connections
between all of these languages it
actually wasn't as obvious that even the
Germanic languages and the Latin based
languages were were so closely connected
when they saw Sanskrit and India is so
closely tied to these languages it in
some ways blew everyone's mind and they
started realizing wow there must have
been a people you know a lot of Western
historians would say people who
originated in Central Asia or out of the
caucuses a lot of Indians would say
maybe out of even North India but you
know you shared this common ancestry but
when you know things like that at least
for me give me chills
because you're like wow there's like
this just you know just over the last
three four thousand years the things
that have happened and humanity you know
modern humans have been you know
physiologically modern humans have been
around for several hundreds of thousands
of years so just even think about all
the things we don't know all the stories
yeah I mean that kind of stuff gives me
chills so that's the kind of thing when
I was a kid I was always interested by
kind of epic stories but sometimes and
if I was sitting in like my seventh
grade history class I wasn't as
interested but when I started to view
history like this then it all became
super interesting so long answer to my
favorite favorite subject that's awesome
so we have some board donations that
have come in oh so much yes thank you
Margaret really appreciate the donation
Mohammed thank you for your donation and
your mom was remind my mother's maiden
name is Ramon so maybe we're related
thank you we're all related as we just
talked about we're all related it's
actually a fun game once again if you
can't impress people with this to just
think about how far you have to go back
to have a common ancestor and obviously
I mean me I don't know maybe 23andme and
stuff can answer these questions but
it's fun to just think about well maybe
someone in Genghis Khan's army you know
thank you you thank you Russell for your
donation Thank You Katerina for your
donation Thank You Daniel for your
donation thanks so much makes it makes a
huge difference and it means a lot and
look it both helps us fuel what we do
but hopefully as you donate you feel
like you are part of our team and our
adventure and our mission and you become
an ambassador for what we do as well
because it's not going to happen you
know we have a lot of people here who
are gung-ho about what we need to do but
obviously something like a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere is a very very big statement it
takes all of us and we're gonna need a
lot of partners and hopefully you also
view yourself as part of that that army
that that movement yeah that can
can help the world get there so thank
you yeah thank you so much this reminder
we're trying to raise $5,000 yes during
this live stream awesome and you can
donate on YouTube on Facebook or you can
go to our website at khanacademy.org
slash donate what I like that question
is my least favorite subject yeah
celebrity gossip yeah and I say that
because sometimes I too get drawn in I
know what you're thinking so no you're
always studying Sanskrit and I minded
there's no way you you yeah you you're
drawn to clickbait but yes I too but I I
don't feel good after I've read some of
those things so it's my least my least
favorite so I don't know what's your
least favorite something um I think my
least favorite subject will probably be
math because I never felt like I was
good at math but I didn't have Khan
Academy when I was growing up so I
didn't as well you are here you should
you should beginning annika I know I
have started a little bit I have been
working through some algebra good good
you know actually the one of the people
who almost was one of the people who
helped me who convinced me to quit my
job to work on Khan Academy he said and
this was a man who had actually started
a bunch of restaurants
a very successful restaurant tour and he
said his name is Jeremiah Hennessey's
the founder of BJ's restaurants and he
just randomly started calling me in 2008
saying like you need to quit your job
because kind of kind of nice to him you
know I was like really who are you and
he said geez restaurants I've been there
that's good casual dining but he was
telling me that he when he hires people
he divides the world between people who
know algebra and don't know algebra and
not that like you know a restaurant
manager is going to have to solve
simultaneous equations and things like
that but algebra builds those critical
thinking skills and that kind of
metacognition that you feel confident
that they could they could learn
higher-order things so I actually do
think that you know if everyone in the
almost everyone has taken algebra at
least in places like the US but if
everyone really mastered algebra
I actually think our level of discourse
would go up
it's not like algebra is the end-all and
Beall but it's one of many things that
people got their critical thinking and
public discourse would go up people
would feel more confident engaging they
wouldn't just defer to experts things
like that so learning algebra I'm trying
all right so some other question - what
are your plans for creating content in
other languages so we have 40
translation and localization projects
going on a Khan Academy around the world
and these are done by incredible
volunteers some of them have local
sponsorships some of them are just very
similar to what I was doing 10 years 10
years ago you know kind of been their
equivalent of their walk-in closets just
trying to make it work trying to be of
service to the the people in their
geographies we have more formal projects
in Latin America we have a partnership
with the lemon foundation in Brazil the
slim Foundation in Mexico Carlos
Rodriguez pasture and Peru have been
incredible supporters and we have teams
in those places that are doing
localization not just of the videos but
the exercises there they're creating
some new content there they're aligning
it to the the various standards in those
areas we also have a fairly decent sized
team 14 people in India that are and we
just had a presentation from them
yesterday where they are not only
localizing the content making that new
content
India's interesting cuz there's many
languages in India but making it work
for the various languages the various
standards so that's our plans right now
that's what we're currently doing but
obviously over the long arc we want to
be able to reach everyone on the planet
mission alright we have some other ones
here
what do you think are the main hurdles
for Khan Academy to achieve its mission
the main hurdles for Khan Academy
achieve its missions so I mean it might
sound a little bit too obvious at a
fundraising livestream detective but yes
it takes resources as I said as I said
before you know our mission you know the
government's are spending trillions of
dollars trying to essentially tackle the
same mission and there a lot is good
coming out of it but we are you know
Khan Academy is the budget of a large
school and and we reach on the order of
a hundred million people every year but
to do that it takes resources so the
first thing is I mean I I probably spend
forty percent of my time fundraising
because if we don't have those resources
we're not going to be able to do
everything we've we've talked about so I
think that's that's number one I think
after that the the main thing is and I
think we've we've been making good
progress on there so I'm not I don't
think it's gonna be like a barrier but I
think it's just you know we have to keep
pushing is finding ways that we can work
more formally with major school
districts that's something we're doing
right now we have a partnership with las
vegas/clark county where students are
using it as part of you know they take
this assessment called the map growth
assessment and now that assessment acts
as a diagnostic and placement for Khan
Academy and then the students are able
to work on that and the district's able
to see how Khan Academy is able to not
only how the map can help influence
personalized plans on Khan Academy but
then Khan Academy can they can
understand how Khan Academy is hopefully
growing the students more than expected
so I think we need to do more things
like that I think we need to be able to
there's a lot of stuff I mean our team
has a huge list of stuff we want to
improve on the experience on Khan
Academy I got out of meeting earlier
this morning where we're talking about
improving our math content even more
adding new content areas we want to
improve the game mechanics make it even
more motivating to use Khan Academy
we're constantly trying to study the
efficacy of what we're doing all of that
takes resources yeah and then I think we
just have to keep doing that add more
subjects you know there's some longer
big picture things that I would want to
eventually tackle like how does the
learning on Khan Academy translate into
opportunity whether that's some form of
credential or connections to internships
or jobs or higher education I think
that's something that we need to figure
out over the next I'd like to start get
started on to the next five years yeah
those are big things but the resources
look for this way our ideas right now
are bigger than our capacity so if we
can raise five thousand dollars that
will move us in that direction and I'll
also do the order of operations problem
which
if anyone really wants me to do it but
I'll do it yeah yes we did just receive
some more donation all right oh and
Michael or Michelle Michelle I'm all con
thank you so much Daniel yeah thank you
so much thank you so much for the
awesome so we have a few minutes left
we're actually gonna move to what we
call the lightning round okay we're
gonna do ten questions and you have ten
seconds to answer each okay each
question are all know that okay yeah
that would that would be really really
hard okay time so tell me when to start
okay cool
so what's your favorite color blue do
you have a black hole badge I have to
not nepotism
yeah miss you misuse of power what is
your favorite exercise like physical
exercise yeah
Daedalus okay who's your favorite
inventor or scientist favorite inventor
or scientist I will just go Leonardo da
Vinci awesome mine too
if you were a classroom teacher what
grade would you want to teach oh oh I
would want a tree I'm gonna cheat I
would teach a mixed age classroom and I
would make the older kids teach the
younger kids and I would be kind of the
Dumbledore of it all all right well we
can go through a couple more of these so
what's your favorite food favorite dark
chocolate awesome favorite chemical
element favorite chem oxygen awesome
what Hogwarts house do you belong to
oh oh
I would like to believe it's a toss-up
between Gryffindor I'll go to a
Gryffindor it's a cop-out yeah um what's
your favorite TV show Oh favorite TV
show
I've been enjoying I've been enjoying
well there's several I enjoyed good
place I like to actually been watching
with my kids where in the world is
Carmen Sandiego on Netflix oh nice
quite good I like them quite like I
can't wait for season 3 I haven't
watched it yet and then the last one
Star Trek or Star Wars you know I think
before some of the new ones came out I
would have said Star Wars but now maybe
Star Trek because I think these mmm they
keep repeating the same plotline yeah
the Empire has this weapon that can
destroy a planet oh you thought anyway
I'm happy to help one more donation Oh
Derek thank you so much Dan thank you so
much oh my seas here too why do you want
to call ups here oh yeah Bar C oh well
did we get to our target do we know I
explained the order of operations
regardless yeah all right cuz alright so
the reason why I've seen this before I
mean yeah the reason why this I think
went viral is some people you know you
learn in school order of operations some
people learn things like PEMDAS which is
like parentheses exponents
multiplication division addition
subtraction you oftentimes learn in
school you do parentheses first that's
obvious but then you do you know
multiply multiplication and division are
kind of equal and it when in doubt you
do them left to right and then addition
and subtraction are kind of equal and
wouldn't that do them left to right
what's tricky here is okay so the
obvious part is to do the parentheses
first I don't think anyone debates that
so if there's that's just four right
there so you have 8 divided by 2 times 4
now if you take the left to right
attitude about it you to 8 divided by 2
is 4 times 4 which is 16 that's one way
people have died the other way
people have said is wait but if I see a
number right next to the parentheses I
feel like I have to multiply that first
right so people say 2 times the 4 that's
8 and then 8/8 would be 1 so you get
either a 16 or 1 I think maybe other
people have got other things but that
might be a little bit more suspicious my
take on it I mean 1 this tells you why
you learn something like order of
operations order operations are just
trying to remove ambiguity from
mathematical expressions like this my
view on this is if I see a number right
next to parentheses I almost view that
is like a light form of parentheses this
is a light form of emphasis of like
you're gonna do that you're going to do
that first so I would my inclination
would be to go for the go to the 1 8
divided by 2 times 4 so 8 divided by 8
which is 1 but this is why if you're
doing any look you know even though
you're doing like a math thesis this is
why it's good to even use more
parentheses why don't use extra
parentheses if you think what you're
saying can be ambiguous in fact that's
not true just in math that's true in
life especially if it's something
important explain it be very clear but
you know these are just symbols that are
trying to convey an idea and you don't
want to be ambiguous and so if you think
it's going to be ambiguous just put
another parentheses around that or if
you really wanted the 8 to be divided by
2 before you multiply then put the
parentheses around that first so I would
say whoever did this just should have
included more parentheses but my
inclination is definitely to do to do
the 2 times the parentheses first
because it's right next to it if there
was a multiplication symbol there then I
probably would have gone left to right
hopefully that's helpful yeah another
donation bar see left yeah was it wasn't
really interested in my explanation yeah
Oh Cory so much Cory organization
awesome so it looks like we've raised
about a thousand so far on YouTube and
830 on Facebook which is super exciting
thank you all for you thank you thank
you so much everyone yeah for sure
so like we were talking about earlier
today is giving Tuesday
and we are a non-profit so any support
is super helpful and a dollar does
provide three hours of learning time so
you can have a huge impact with your
gift and you can always give at Khan
Academy org slash donate but yeah I
think we're at time for today awesome do
you have any last things you'd like to
know well you know thank you for viewing
and you know it means a lot that y'all
are part of this journey with us you
know it's a big audacious mission I tell
the team here all the time that you know
there was a time there was just you know
mean a walk-in closet that was kind of
the first chapter of Khan Academy then
around 2009-2010 we were able to get
some of the first support to start
building this incredible team you know
here's some management advice higher up
then you can't go wrong that way and I
think kind of kind of means now entering
a phase where you know we reach tens of
millions of students but we want to be
able to reach hundreds of millions and
reach them in a really deep and
substantive way so that you know that
story of Jason the young man who was in
prison for 15 years and you know we have
people in places like Afghanistan who
you know the young girls who the Taliban
forbid forbade from going to school who
are able to learn on a Khan Academy and
you know now they're doing physics
research we want to multiply those
stories by a thousand fold or million
fold and you know I hope that everyone
all of us and everyone watching that are
our kids or our grandchildren can't
imagine a world where a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere isn't
essentially a human right so thank you
for for helping us move towards towards
that that vision thank you thank you so
much have a great day
you